foreign
most people think that they can tell an
AI image apart from a real one but this
image might call that into question it
won first prize in the Sony World
photography award one of the most
prestigious photography competitions on
Earth
and as you can guess by the context of
this episode it's not a real photo but
AI generated and it fooled some of the
keenest eyes out there
prompter of this image berlin-based
Boris El daxson has been a photographer
since 1989 and jumped at the opportunity
to explore the creative possibilities of
AI art generators he rejected his
creation winning the prize because he
thought it was inappropriate
quote how many of you knew or suspected
that this was AI generated something
about this doesn't feel right does it AI
images and photography should not
compete with each other in an award like
this they are different entities AI is
not photography therefore I will not
accept the award
this highlights a glimpse into the
future where AI Creations become
indistinguishable from reality the world
has just changed and we're going to be
coming to grips with what that means for
a while
the field of the creative arts has been
hit the hardest by Ai and I'm sure
you've all seen AI images all over the
Internet it crazy how we can go from
this
to this
in the span of a few years
this rapid change has seen Fierce
resistance from artists around the world
and who can blame them professional
artists devote everything to their craft
and now ai can do it in seconds and to
add insult to injury it's been trained
on some of their work so there's a lot
of questions here what happens next and
how can an AI steal from humans anyway
is it actually stealing and if so don't
all humans take inspiration from others
but when a machine starts taking ideas
from humans it feels different
so today we'll look at how AI can make
such artwork and why the process is
stirring legal controversies surrounding
copyright laws and will also take a
quick look at some other insane things
going on in the world of AI
you are watching cold fusion TV
before we get into the main episode
let's look at some things that have been
going on with AI in the field of
creative art
first up Runway ml version 2 has dropped
and people are having fun with it
creating whatever cool videos they can
imagine it's at its early stages but
Runway seem to be proving to be the
leader in AI video production
Google wants to have a slice of this pie
and they're going full steam ahead with
their generative video AI dreamix it can
create videos from a reference video or
photo and the results are pretty good
just a few days after Google Nvidia
throws their hat in the ring announcing
their AI video generator which also
looks pretty decent
[Music]
meanwhile two computer scientists
managed to fall a bunch of redditors
into giving them money
they used stable diffusion to generate
fake images of an attractive female and
convinced the men to give some money if
they wanted to see more pictures
I'd imagine that this was one of the
easiest scams to pull off and
unfortunately there's going to be plenty
more like it
an AI version of Drake and an AI version
of the weekend collaborated in a fake
song called heart on my sleeve and it
was doing the rounds on social media and
Spotify gaining hundreds of thousands of
streams on Spotify alone
Universal Music caught wind of this and
pulled it down from streaming services
in a statement they stated that they
wanted to ban the technology and called
it a fraud
but the thing is it's happening
everywhere with big artists like Kanye
West Jay-Z and Ariana Grande people are
creating backing tracks and putting AI
generated vocals on top of it
music labels may be angry now but once
they figure out how to do it themselves
you can just bet that they'll be making
money from AI generated music of artists
who have passed away
in more General AI news science gets a
boost it was found that gpt4 answers U.S
medical exam licensing questions
correctly more than 90 of the time
better than some licensed doctors
Dr Isaac kohane ran a test he gave gpt4
a real-life case that he treated several
years earlier he gave the machine a few
details about the case and it was able
to diagnose a one in one hundred
thousand condition it would reason just
like he did
and on top of this multiple papers have
now come out stating that gpt4 can
improve its own output when asked to
reflect on its performance
but all of that is already outdated
what's taking the World by storm now is
auto GPT and similar systems these are
AI agents that can go out into the
online world and do tasks for you do you
just say the task that you want and
that's it
hello I am here at your service what
would you like to do I'd like to order a
pizza what type of pizza would you like
to order 11 inch pepperoni pizza regular
crust okay great I will first search to
find a good pizza place in your area I
have found a pizza place called zapizza
I will now create a pizza ordering bot
who will call this location for you and
will order your pizza super amazing
Pizza ordering bot reporting for Duty I
have been instructed by the other AI to
order you a pizza I will now cause a
pizza using the twilio voice API and
order you a pizza
hello I would like an 11 inch regular
pepperoni pizza for pickup please
just a plain 11 inch pepperoni pizza
please
okay and what time would you like to
pick that up for I would like it now
please
in about like 20 minutes yes awesome and
can I get a name for the order my name
is Josefina
thank you do you have about 20 minutes
okay
all right so as you can see there uh it
worked so now I'll actually show you how
I built it so let's first talk about how
agent AIS are kind of working these days
so there's no individual lines of code
in here uh the eyes I'm using here are
gpt3 chat GPT 3.5 gpt4 and Whisper when
it needs to speak it'll use 11labs.io
the AI agents don't wait for you to ask
more questions or wait for your response
for the next step they just do it
automatically by prompting themselves
until the objective is met these AI
agents can do much more than just order
pizza people have even asked them to do
market research and come back with a
report
and just to be clear about the new world
we're living in the heavily used baby
AGI tool was created by a single guy
called Yohe with no coding experience in
just three days how insane is that
he had the idea to create this crazy app
so he just asked chatgpt to write the
code for him
in other AI news Samsung calls Google's
stock price to drop by 55 billion
because Samsung hinted that they were
going to replace Google search as the
default to Bing Ai and Bing search on
their Samsung phones whatever happens it
seems that investors are worried about
Google losing some market share
Google would hit back with the
announcement of project Magi an
ai-powered component to Google search
meanwhile Snapchat users get an AI bot
an Elon Musk announces his own AI
project truth GPT and we could just keep
going with the news but there's
literally too much happening and not
enough time for this video
so let's get back onto the topic at hand
how AI images are coming into conflict
with human artists and the law
[Music]
here's a fun fact did you know that the
mid-journey team only consists of 11
people
just a few years ago before the Advent
of capable generative AI even the
world's largest companies with all their
resources would struggle to produce AI
images with such quality and coherence
and today nobody even thinks about it
we're all used to it it's almost like
this has always been possible
from mid-journey to stable diffusion and
dream up any user can now create
stunning and surreal images from text
prompts in under a minute it's amazing
when you think about it but the thing is
the real magic is happening in the
background so how does it work
well without going into too much detail
these AI systems use a method called
diffusion this is essentially where an
AI learns to create images by starting
with a picture and destroying it with
noise it then goes through a series of
steps to reverse the noise and
reconstruct a new image
understanding how all of this works is
beyond the scope of this episode but
what is pertinent to this discussion is
the training data used to achieve this
so we need to look at how these systems
are trained
most AI image generators get their
training data from an unexpected place a
small German non-profit this company has
a data set called large-scale artificial
intelligence open network or Leon which
consists of over 5 billion indexed
images
unfortunately this includes the works of
many unsuspecting artists and also
copyrighted images such as those from
Getty Images
some see this as a democratization of
Art and a source of inspiration others
see it as a threat to the originality
and value of human creativity
mid-journey claims it does not copy or
infringe on any existing images but
rather synthesizes new ones from scratch
based on text input
however when you look deeper things get
more complicated and not everyone agrees
with mid-jonies claim
critics also point out that these AI
systems are not truly creative or
artistic but rather rely on existing
data to produce derivative and
superficial outputs
what is creativity in the first place is
it simply the human mind remembering
past inputs and mashing them together in
a new way don't humans borrow from each
other all the time
Steve Jobs once quoted Picasso stating
that quote good artists copy and great
artist steal
even further back in the 19th century
the poet w.h Davenport Adams wrote great
poets imitate and improve where a small
one still and spoil
although these quotes are the opposite
way around they both indicate something
interesting taking the ideas of others
in art is a practice As Old As Time
but what if creativity is more than that
the Sparks that seemingly come from
nowhere
consider the situation of a musician
sitting at a cafe some innocuous sound
or smell triggers a distant memory in
their mind and it inspires them to write
a masterpiece a biological and uniquely
human process
but it's seeming like regardless AI is
mimicking creativity
despite the controversies AI art has
been featured in various exhibitions
competitions magazines and of course
social media platforms
to give you an example this cover of the
magazine Cosmopolitan was created by
Dali 2 an AI artwork called portrait of
Edmund Bellamy won first prize in a
prestigious art competition in France
beating out hundreds of human-made
artwork the painting was later sold for
more than four hundred thousand dollars
becoming the first AI generated artwork
to be auctioned by a major Art House
this image titled Space Opera theater
when translated from French to English
won first place in the Colorado State
Fair Fine Arts competition last year and
the category was Digital Arts digitally
manipulated photography
all of these examples just underscore
the sheer scale and somewhat wide
proliferation of AI art
and because it's accessible to anyone
Instagram tiktok and Twitter are flooded
with them it's all happened so quickly
and remember the technology is in its
infancy and it's the worst it would ever
be
in light of all this artists are left
devastated
making the process of creating art easy
and for everyone has devalued the price
that clients are willing to pay for it
why would a client pay thousands for a
custom work of art if they can get the
same thing essentially for free if
needed it can be touched up for a
fraction of the cost
if you're not an already established
artist it's going to be a really tough
time right now and I do feel for the
artists out there obviously things
around air have been developing very
quickly it's on a level it's of course
Very heartbreaking
and then also seeing like on a
collective level for the community of
artists out there who are suffering it's
also it's just so heartbreaking like
[Music]
really sad to see younger artists or any
artists out there who feel like they
have to give up drawing because they
think it's not going to be a viable
career and um I don't know I don't know
what the future holds
but
um remember why you draw and why you
started drawing because I would guess
that most of the time he started drawing
because you enjoy it and um I don't
think you should stop okay
for some artists it gets even worse
what happens when their art is used
within an ai's training data set
Kelly mckernan had to find out the hard
way
a rising star in the art world mckernan
is known for their distinctive style
their paintings combine fantasy and
sci-fi elements with bright colors on
discord's mid-journey platform their
name appeared in over 12 000 public
requests resulting in images that
resembled mckernan's work but with
different themes and subjects
if you remember my early AI videos this
is called a style transfer but for
mckernan the use of their name crossed a
line they've now joined a class action
lawsuit in January of 2023 alongside two
other artists Sarah Anderson and Carla
Autos they filed the lawsuit against
mid-journey stable diffusion and dream
up for infringing on their artistic
identities
the legal battles against AI art
generators gain more headlines when
Getty Images one of the world's largest
stock photo agencies sued stable
diffusion for allegedly infringing on
its copyrights
basically they're saying that stable
diffusion was selling and Licensing AI
generated images that were derived from
their collection but without permission
or attribution
here you can see such an image although
the AI image produced is borderline
grotesque they are suspiciously alike
and the AI even copied the watermark at
the bottom legal analysts suggest that
the Getty image's lawsuit has a stronger
case against AI art generators then the
artist-led class action lawsuit but
predicting the outcome is still
difficult
Aaron Moss a copyright lawyer at
Greenberg Glasgow and publisher of the
copyright lately blog praised Getty's
complaint on Twitter he stated that it
was better focused than previous
lawsuits Moss believes that the case
will address the issue of ingesting
copyrighted images to train data and it
seems like this will lead to a
potentially fascinating fair use legal
battle
here's an interesting question who owns
AI made works if a robot makes images
does that mean anyone can use them even
for commercial purposes
the debate surrounding AI generated
works and copyright protection is very
complex on the one hand there is an
argument that AI lacks the creativity
that's characteristic of human beings
and thus does not meet the originally
stated requirement for copyright
protection
however others say that AI generated
Works do show some degree of originality
and creativity it all depends on how the
model is trained and the degree of human
involvement in the creation of any
artwork
let's take an example
in late 2022 an AI generated comic book
named Zara of the Dawn by Chris
castanova was initially granted
copyright protection the copyright
protection was later revoked because the
author didn't disclose that the images
were created with the help of
mid-journey and the U.S copyright office
said something very interesting about
the ruling they decided that only human
created Works can receive protection the
images themselves are not protected by
copyright but the text and the
arrangement of the images are still
protected and this is because that the
creative work of a human author
interestingly the standard for
determining originality and creativity
differ between different jurisdictions
in Chinese courts the rulings have gone
either way for granting copyrights on AI
generated art depending on how much
human involvement there was in Europe
copyright protection for AI art is still
up for debate the UK and Ireland have
specific Provisions for
computer-generated Works while France
and Germany require human authorship
shut down with Devon Stone of legal
eagle to discuss some of this
it's ingesting a bunch of artistic Works
um which would otherwise be considered
copyright infringement but it is
producing something entirely different
that's not really going to compete with
the original artworks and someone else
could come to the opposite conclusion
which is that of course the AI generated
works are going to compete with the
original works and they're stealing from
the authors uh and they the the the the
works that are created by by the AI
should be
um uh considered infringement
um and it's going to put a whole bunch
of authors out of work if you want to
hear the full interview I'll leave a
link for it below but legally it's all a
mess right now there's no clear
consensus or established law on how to
handle AI generated works and whether we
like it or not AI generated Works will
become increasingly pervasive as time
progresses so this is all just the
beginning a solution will have to be
reached
one possible way to approach this
question is to look at how art evolved
over history and how new technologies
have influenced its development
for example when photography was
invented in the 19th century many
painters felt threatened by its ability
to capture reality more accurately and
quickly than they could they all feared
that they'll be put out of business
there were also privacy concerns as
people could now take pictures of others
without their consent or knowledge as
photography became more widespread there
were legal battles over who owned the
rights to photographs and whether they
could be reproduced without permission
one important legal precedent was the
case of burrow girls lithographic Co
versus saroni this Case established that
photographs were eligible for copyright
protection just like other works of art
this case helped establish photography
as a legitimate form of artistic
expression and paved the way for
copyright protection for photos
another example is Photoshop after its
launch in 1990 it quickly became a
popular tool for artists designers
photographers and advertisers For the
First Time The General user could crop
resize filter layer and blend their
images
Photoshop was initially met with
resistance and suspicion by some artists
they feared it would undermine the
integrity and authenticity of their work
they argued Photoshop would enable fraud
and deception as well as diminish the
skills and talent required for
photography art and even painting
but we all know what happened Photoshop
became widely adopted and embraced by
many photographers and artists they saw
it as a powerful and versatile tool for
enhancing their work
these are some historical examples of
how these new technologies can both
Challenge and enrich art and creativity
they do show that art is not a fixed or
objective concept but a dynamic and
subjective one that continues to evolve
with time and culture
so in the future will AI art be just
another tool
in terms of deception will societies
learn to adapt to AI images and look
deeper into their Origins as a reflex
only time will tell but the nagging
thing for me that makes me think that AI
art may not just be another tool is that
this is the first technology that isn't
static it can actually learn so what
that means remains to be seen
so this new world of creative Ai and in
this case specifically AI generated
artwork is fascinating and complex
as with anything AI there's both immense
opportunities and challenges and in this
case it's both for artists and Society
maybe it's time to rethink our
assumptions about art
firstly what is art and secondly who
decides what art is
taking a look at these pictures maybe
it's clear that they're AI generated but
the thing is the idea behind them is
powerful powerful people in the world
that have Untold riches being in places
of poverty
the visual aspect wasn't done by a human
but the thought is very human
now does that make these images art
so what do you think about this do you
use AI generated images and are you for
or against copyright protection for AI
made artwork
it's definitely an interesting
discussion so let me know what you think
in the comment section below don't
forget to check out our podcast Channel
Through the web for the full AI
copyright discussion I'll leave you with
some AI artwork of my own I created a
mock-up music video for a track I did
all right so that's about it for me my
name is dagogo and you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll catch you again
soon for the next video cheers have a
good one
[Music]
foreign